president Trump won the New Hampshire
primary yesterday the New York Post is
reporting that a woman has become
pregnant and Chuck Schumer wants to take
away your six Milly lip pillies of Zen
nicotine all of those stories in
ascending order of newsworthiness and
importance and more I'm Michael nolles
this the Michael NES
[Music]
show
welcome back to the show the libs who
want all of you smoking the devil's
lettuce who want to legalize the sin
spinach the Haitian oregano the Peruvian
parsley you know what I'm talking about
I'm talking about pot those same people
want to take away your tasty little
pouches of salt and
nicotine
as far as I can tell forget the Trump
indictments forget the 2024 election no
issue is more likely to bring America to
Civil War than the libs taking away the
rights Zin okay no no issue the the
American right is extremely
peaceful I think they could go berserk
if you try to deport them from Zimbabwe
so we'll get to that very important
story in a second first though the far
less newsworthy story the story that we
all knew most of us the reasonable
people knew it was going to happen for a
long time president Trump won the New
Hampshire primary by a considerable
margin it wasn't a complete and total
blowout it wasn't you know 90 to 10 or
something but this is now effectively a
two-person race Ronda santis barely
showed up in the polls obviously because
he suspended his campaign a number of
days ago uh Trump won 54.6 to 4
3.1 at last update the numbers are still
going to change as those last votes come
in but that's a sizable margin and 11
and a half points in a two-man race
we're told that Trump is this uh
despised figure he divides the base
we've all heard he's got a ceiling he
can't get above 30% support 40% support
that's not true he's got a clear
majority of Republicans support even
when it comes down to a two-person race
even where there's a clear distinction
do you want the candidate who's more
moderate and more Centrist and more
friendly friendlier rather with the
Chamber of Commerce and the GOP
establishment or do you want this crazy
populist Maniac Donald Trump even there
when it's a a really clear distinction
Trump wins by over 11 points and he's
very happy about it and he gives a
victory speech today I have to tell you
it was very interesting because I said
wow what a great Victory but then
somebody ran up to the stage all dressed
up
nicely when it was at 7 but now I just
walked up and it's at
14 but she ran up when it was
7 and you know we have to do what's good
for our party and she was up and I said
wow she's doing uh like a speech like
she won she didn't win she lost and you
know last last week we had a little bit
of a problem and if you remember Ron was
very upset because she ran up and she
pretended she won
Iowa and I looked around I said didn't
she come in third yeah she came in third
so Trump turning up the attacks just a
little bit on Nikki Haley notice these
by Trump standards are not vicious
attacks at all this is not Nikki Haley's
dad killed JFK okay this is not Nikki
Haley is the worst politician in America
soldier down the river to the globalists
all he's doing is poking fun at her
concession speeches because Nikki Haley
is an extremely talented politician and
she has framed her concession speeches
in Iowa and New Hampshire as quasi
Victory speeches and clearly it's worked
she had a great showing here 43.6% for a
campaign that most people wrote off at
the very beginning is impressive and you
know some of us hate to say I told you
so but some of us at the beginning said
don't write off Nikki Haley she's very
impressive she's been able to do very
well with the establishment part of the
GOP when she was governor of South
Carolina and since she's left the Biden
Administration the Trump Administration
rather during the Biden Administration
uh but also she did pretty well when she
was working for Trump when she was UN
Ambassador with the populist side and
the more conservative side and the
right-wing side so I said don't write
her off and there were a lot of great
candidates on on that stage in the early
days Ronda santis was considered the
real challenge to Donald Trump and she
lasted longer than he did and she did
better in the polls and she's she's
going to perform better in the primaries
but still the numbers just aren't there
New Hampshire was Nikki Haley's best
shot and she did very well 43.6% is an
impressive showing but it's not good
enough so she has no path to the
nomination and that is why the
Republican National Committee Rona
McDaniel is calling on her to drop out
I'm looking at the math and the path
going forward and I don't see it for
Nikki Haley I think she's run a great
campaign but I do think there is a
message that's coming out from the
voters which is very clear we need to
unite around our eventual nominee which
is going to be Donald Trump and we need
to make sure we beat Joe Biden it is 10
months away till the November election
and we can't wait any longer to put our
foot on the gas to beat the worst
president to beat a president that's
kept our borders open allowed fentanyl
to pour through allowed inflation to to
go rampant he is hurting the American
people and we need to do everything we
can to unite so that we can defeat
him I totally agree with ra here
I almost totally agree with ra I agree
it's in the best interests of the RNC
for Nikki to drop out and to Rally a
around Trump who is the presumptive
nominee barring a lightning strike from
the sky or from some democrat Trump is
going to be the nominee I agree that
it's better for the Republican voters I
agree that it's better for the
conservative movement I agree that it's
better for the country because it will
give uh Republicans a chance to unite to
win over moderates and independents and
maybe some Democrats to conserve their
money you know every dollar that's spent
in a primary that's going nowhere is a
dollar that cannot be spent on a general
election against Joe Biden I I agree
with r there I don't agree that
Republicans absolutely have to do it now
and this is the moment we have no time
to waste I I'm not sure of that we have
a primary for a purpose and Nikki Haley
has every right to stay in this primary
as long as she wants the problem here is
all the incentives that the RNC has and
the Republican voters have and the
conservative movement has all of those
incentives don't line up with Nikki
Haley's incentives because if I were ra
I'd be calling for Nikki to drop out but
if I were Nikki I would not drop out
Nikki Haley has no incentive at this
moment to drop out of the race and so
she's not now you've all heard the
chatter among the political class
they're falling all over themselves
saying this race is over well I have
news for all of them wo New Hampshire is
first in the nation it is not the last
in the nation this race is far from over
there are dozens of States left to go
and the next one is my sweet state of
South
Carolina at one point in this campaign
there were 14 of us running and we were
at 2% in the
polls well I'm a fighter and I'm Scrappy
W and now we're the last one standing
next to Donald Trump and today we got
close to half of the vote we still have
a ways to go but we keep moving up all
right what Nikki said here is at least
half true she is Scrappy she did wind up
the last person on the stage fighting
Donald Trump
she doesn't want to drop out of the race
she
sure something she says that isn't true
she says our next state is South
Carolina that's not true the next state
is Nevada Nikki Haley is not even on the
ballot in Nevada because the Nevada
Primary caucus is divided between a
primary and a caucus and all the
Republican candidates chose to
participate in the caucus organized by
the Republican Party Nikki Haley chose
to participate in the primary that was
pushed by Nevada state legislators over
the objections of the Republican party
she's the only person in that primary so
it won't count it won't it won't help
her in any way toward the nomination but
Nikki Haley is not running to beat
Donald Trump it is not possible for
Nikki Haley to beat Donald Trump in the
primary and she's a smart woman so
that's not what she's doing she is
staying in this race for other reasons
and those
reasons remain likely to serve her we'll
get to that in one second first though I
want to talk about something really
important and that's meat I want to talk
about good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com code no if you have not
already checked out good ranchers new
year new meat special you got to do it
right now when you subscribe to any box
of good ranchers they will add over two
pounds of pre-trimmed better than
organic chicken breasts to your order
for free not once not twice but on every
order for a year I am actually really
upset with good ranchers right now and
it's nothing that they've done it's
entirely my fault but it involves good
ranchers which is I subscribe to to a
very large box of good ranchers every
month as you know it's me sweet little
Alisa the two boys you know when we're
I'm of Italian extraction my little boy
is you know he eats a lot and and so I
get I ran out I ran out this month and
so I had to eat non-good ranchers meat
and I'm sure I could have texted them I
could have ordered another B
but I it was deeply upsetting this
happened almost a week ago I'm still
thinking about it don't make the mistake
I did go to goodranchers.com use code
nolles right now enjoy free chicken in
2024 plus an additional 20 bucks off
your order and and order a a two times
bigger box than you think you're going
to want change the way you buy meat by
switching to the best out there good
ranchers code nolles claim over 200
bucks in free chicken save big this New
Year goodranchers.com American Meat
delivered Nikki Haley has no incentive
to drop out of this race
because she might wind up the number two
person and historically the
GOP allows the number two person to be
become the nominee in the next
cycle we're in a weird cycle right now
where president Trump is running for a
non-consecutive second term we haven't
seen anything like that for over 100
years but in Prior Cycles in 2008 Mitt
Romney was the number two guy 2012 he
becomes the nominee in 2000 at the
beginning of the Bush term John McCain
was the number two guy in 2008 he
becomes the Republican nominee Bob Dole
had been running for president in oh
since what 1980 or earlier 1996 Bob Dole
he paid his dues he he worked real hard
he becomes the Republican nominee 1992
obviously George W George HW Bush was
the number two guy in 1980 at the
beginning of the Reagan term he became
vice president a lot of the
conservatives didn't even like George
Bush he was he was a compromised
candidate to unite the party Pat
Buchanan primaried him as the
Conservative candidate there were there
were a lot of conservatives who who
really didn't like him and yet he gets
the tap 1976 the number two guy was
Ronald Reagan 1980 he becomes the
nominee and on and on and
on so Nikki is saying okay maybe I could
be the number two person and then I
could be the nominee or maybe I could
seem like the alternative for the
Republican party or maybe I could just
raise my profile or maybe I could do
this or maybe I could do that she's got
a ton of money from the coke Network
she's already put herself on the outs
with the Trump Administration I don't
think there's any world in which Trump
hires her for some cabinet post because
she worked for for him she was popular
there then she turned on him he got
angry about that then she supported him
again then she turned on again to run I
just don't think he's going to hire her
again so what's why not it's kind of
just a free option for her she basically
only can gain she has very very little
to lose unless Trump goes scorched Earth
on her but he's probably not going to
because she doesn't represent a real
threat so he's going to remain largely
focused on Joe
Biden now much more important story than
whatever's going on in the GOP
race these little guys these little six
mill lip pillies you know what I'm
talking about I'm talking
about Zin Chuck
Schumer top Democrat out there in the
Senate one of the leading Democrats in
this country for
decades he wants to take away your tasty
little nicotine pouches Senate Majority
Leader Chuck Schumer is calling for
federal action to crack down on a
product called Zen he says the nicotine
pouches pose a danger to teens as they
use them as an alternative to
ecigarettes pouch packed with problems
high levels of nicotine so today I'm
delivering a warning to parents because
these nicotine pouches seem to lock
their sights on young kids teenagers and
even lower and then use the social media
to hook them Senator Schumer is urging
the FTC and the FDA to investigate Zen
for concerns related relating to
marketing and health effects we reached
out to zenver comment but have not yet
heard
back I agree with almost everything
Senator Schumer just said these little
nicotine pouches they can pack a punch
some of them just basically have the
same dose of nicotine as a single
cigarette but some it's more like three
cigarettes or four cigarettes or more so
I I
agree I'm not the leader of Zimbabwe
okay I didn't lead a revolution in
brodia to become the leader of that
state I'm not the prime minister of
zindia I'm not I'm not even the mayor of
Cincinnati but I've popped in a nice
little lip py every now and again and
it's amazing I you I think that's
actually what neural link will feel like
it feels like you're just taking an
electrical charge and plugging it into
your brain stem and then all your
synapses fire on again and you just
start working I have a friend of mine
who is now hopelessly addicted to Zen he
says that that substance makes him a
better husband and a better father and
now he no longer needs these
trivialities these silly little things
like sleep he can just stay awake all
the time and be very productive and but
so I agree it's extremely addictive
young people are getting hooked on it I
to and I'm not I'm not saying that's
good but I'm just a little confused that
Chuck Schumer's coming after the Zin
because Chuck Schumer here just about a
year and a half ago partnered up with
other top Democrats in the Senate to try
to legalize
pot the Canabis Administration and
Opportunity Act this comprehensive
legislation would end Federal cannabis
prohibition by removing cannabis from
the Controlled Substances
Act Empower states to create their own
cannabis laws ensure Federal Regulation
protect Public Safety and Health how are
you going you're going to protect Public
Safety and Health by legalizing by
encouraging a substance that not only is
a gateway to other harder drugs but just
in it self makes people really fat and
dumb and slow and is extremely addictive
even though all the potheads say it's
not addictive at all but these are the
people who always insist that marijuana
is not addictive are the ones who wake
and bake and just rip the
old California cumin I don't know I'm
running out of terms for pot but they
they do it all day long oh man it's not
addictive I could quit any time and it's
my whole
personality it cures every disease man
and Chuck Schumer wants to legalize that
if you legalize pot who do you think is
going to use it you think it's just
going to be a granny for the first time
is going to spark up a bong no I think
kids largely are going to use it in
exactly the same way that kids are now
testing out these Zin packets I don't
think that's a good thing but why is
Schumer okay with one and not the other
Tucker had a great monologue on this a
while ago I don't think he was the first
person to point it out but he
articulated what a lot of us we're
thinking which is that
today marijuana is left Co marijuana is
a thing that Libs do I know there are PL
there are plenty of people who listen to
this show who love just puffing on the
old Devil's lettuce but o broadly
speaking it's a left-wing thing and
broadly speaking nicotine is a
right-wing thing the cigars and the
pipes and even the cigarettes today are
a right-wing thing yes there are people
on the left who smoke tobacco and use
nicotine mostly it's rightwing you think
of some you know uh big cowboy hat
wearing good old boy from the down south
wearing wearing spurs on his boots and
packing a big fat lucky Lipper of dip
that's not a left-wing person that's not
some vegan lesbian in Brooklyn that's a
right- Winger so that's how it's coded
now and Chuck Schumer supports the
left-wing substance and the left-wing
substance coincidentally makes you kind
of lazy and dumb and passive as Tucker
noted in his viral monologue and the
right substance makes you more alert it
makes you uh think more quickly and more
clearly it it uh keeps you up so that
you can do more work it's it's not it's
not a party drug you know it's not the
sort of thing where you just put on some
stupid cartoon and eat a bowl of ice
cream when you know when you when you're
throwing in Zin packets or even ripping
cigarettes or something like that it's
the image you get is someone who's who's
frenetic it's someone who's who's really
active and and that's a right-wing thing
that's why and so the reason that
Schumer and the Democrats are going
after this I think is not even just
because they in part it's because they
want to encourage people to be passive
and lazy and dumb but e even more than
that it's because they want to support
their own tabos and they want to oppose
the right-wing tabos they want to
support their own standards they want to
oppose the right-wing
standards that this is the exact same
point I've made with free speech notably
in my book speechless controlling words
controlling Minds thank you the battle
here is not between free speech on the
one hand and censorship on the other
it's about competing sets of standards
and Norms it's the same thing with the
substances I don't even really like Zen
I mean I'm making a lot of Zen puns
right now but I don't like any addictive
substances really I don't have an
addictive personality I love cigars but
I I I am not just saying I could quit
any time I actually have quit for very
long periods and you don't feel any
physical Drive I like it but you take
them or leave them
okay tobacco has there's a good piece by
the Theologian Mike Foley who points out
that tobacco relates in a way to the
tripartite soul the tobacco pipe that's
like the logical part of your soul you
think of the philosopher you think of
the stem and the bowl the male and the
female then the cigars they're the
thotics and I guess you'd include Zen
and dip in that that's more the
repetitive part of the soul I don't like
the repetitive stuff I don't like
anything that's really addictive but I
would much rather live in a culture that
exalts working hard and being more alert
and being more conscious and uh uh being
more fastidious about your work than a
culture that supports the chum gang and
munchies and giggling at stupid cartoons
and getting fat and voting for Democrats
and that's what it's about it's what it
comes down to for Schumer he want to he
wants to oppose the right-wing
substances promote the leftwing
substances oppose the right-wing rituals
support the leftwing rituals because if
if you create a culture that is leftwing
you're going to get more leftwing voters
speaking of really good clean substances
you got to check
out woke tears water are you sick of
companies trying to turn you into a big
lib it seems like this leftism this
wokeism is everywhere it's in the air we
breathe it's even in the water we drink
and that is why there is a new hydration
product out there to help protect you
from the libs and that is woke tears
water maybe took a little inspiration
from our Tumblr woke tears water is a
new brand of drinking water bottled
right here in the United States by
people who know what a woman is made
from Pure melted snowflakes H see what
we did there woke tears they don't see
color that's why they self-identify as
transparent the most transparent water
in the world well everyone else is water
is just water woke tears provides a
refreshing gulp of laughter in a world
thirsty for sanity not only will woke
tears keep you hydrated but you will
always have a conversation starter if
you want to try woke Tew water visit
woke Tew water.com indulge today in
laughter and hydration two of the most
important things in life woke tarwater
decom today lady Ballers is the
hilarious story of a group of male
losers who can't win against other men
and decide to identify as women
to join a women's basketball league it's
absurd it's ridiculous it's laughable
laughable is a synonym for ridiculous
yes it's happening right now in the
world here's a quick look at what is
being called the most triggering movie
of the decade LEF are losing it over
lady Ballers nothing's changed this
movie is a straight up and intentional
transphobic hate crime what I see you
the lady Ballers movie needs to be
banned I'll cancel you I get the blinds
please tood
11 the most toxic BS you've ever seen
you're a Monster yeah next level hate
speech propaganda that's it that's the
pitch watch the most triggering comedy
of the
decade lady Ballers streaming
exclusively on Deli wire plus I like
that new trailer with all of the very
complimentary reviews on it don't wait
watch lady Ballers the movie that
Hollywood did not make so we did did
exclusively on dailywire plus now this
is society without any self control
according to a video that has gone viral
self-control now is colonialism one of
the many ways that Colonial mental
health Wellness self-help culture shows
up in our society is through the
framework of control Power and
domination and the way that that looks
like is using verbiage like we just need
to be able to control our our thoughts
our feelings our mind our bodies this
idea that you need to force yourself
into a state of discomfort in order to
regulate your emotions and ultimately
this extends into the medical and
psychiatric industrial complex where
these very tools of force are used as an
extension of policing of coloniality of
systems of Oppression that are at play
tactics of domination can never be used
to heal from complex trauma and ongoing
forms of trauma that the marginalized
are experiencing on an everyday basis
and it becomes dangerous when we
conflate things like regulating our
emotions with controlling
them this is a totally wrong view of
psychology the field and what goes on in
your head but I really like this video
because I love being proven right even
if I hate to say I told you so I love
being proven right and in in this case
I've said for years now
that the the left-wing version of
Liberation it's going to start out with
talking about systems of Oppression and
colonialism and the patriarchy and
Society but what it's really going to
come down to is a much more radical
Liberation not just from some political
order not just from some system of laws
it's going to be a radical Liberation
from morality and from self-control and
from the self
itself and that's exactly what this
woman is saying she's saying if you are
told to control yourself at all it's a a
form of
Oppression I I in a way I guess it it's
limits it's placing limits on certain
desires so that you have the freedom to
enact other
desires yeah that's it it it does
restrict certain things because you
can't really be free if you don't
restrict certain things if you don't
restrict your intake of heroin you're
not going to be free to not be addicted
to heroin and go do other things that's
totally true she says any form of
psychology that makes you uncomfortable
is oppressive and
bad she has a static view of
comfort part of I agree that there are
all sorts of problems in the
psychological profession obviously but
psychology at its very very best
counseling at its very very best just
discipline at its very very best is not
going to make you feel uncomfortable all
the time it's going to make you feel
uncomfortable at first because you've
got a problem that's why you're going to
see the psychologist it's going to make
you feel uncomfortable at first and then
it's going to
change what gives you comfort and what
gives you discomfort people who have
psychological problems get comfort from
perverted things that harm them and so
they go to a psychologist to try to
change that Comfort just means to give
you strength right and and so sometimes
we need a little tough love and that
will make us feel a little less
comfortable but in a deeper sense it
will give us much more strength if if
you have some really perverse desire you
know you're
U I don't know you're a you're a
masochist let's say you're an anorexic
and you go to the psychologist you say I
get comfort from starving myself you say
well yeah that maybe that makes you feel
good because you've got a perverted
psychology but it's going to kill you if
you don't fix it so what you've got to
do is shift what you understand to be
good and what you understand to be bad
shift your perception of reality which
is currently defective and desire good
things and then those good and true
things will give you comfort eating a
sandwich will give you some
comfort being a healthy body weight will
give you some comfort that's what you
got to
do to shift things AB absolutely the
case but but we have this radical view
of Liberation now including on the right
that says freedom is just do whatever
the heck you want whatever that even
means and so this this was always where
that kind of view of freedom was going
to end
up we can't we can't control anything
anymore the president of the United
States can't control his own voice th
this is the soaring and sophisticated
rhetoric today coming out from the
president we'll teach Donald Trump an a
valuable lesson don't mess with the
women of America unless you want to get
the
benefit CH and at least but Biden still
has the he has the intonation to some
degree he's still got the the physical
movements the politician
gesticulations he just doesn't speak
coherently anymore he was never you know
he was never Pericles but he doesn't he
doesn't even speak intelligibly anymore
so it's like a baby it's kind of sad but
it's there's something almost cute about
it you know when you got a little baby
and the baby's learning to talk and the
baby will mimic your fa facial
expressions and your intonation and your
and your your
uh Dynamics in volume so
what that's that's the president can we
play it one more time I just I want to
see if there's any lesson I can take
away there we'll teach Donald Trump an a
valuable lesson don't mess with a women
America unless you want to get the
benefit don't okay don't mess with the
women of America unless you want
to part of this could be physical too
because Biden obviously uh has
artificial teeth and that's no knock on
it our our first president arguably our
greatest president had artificial teeth
too so but his are not they're not glued
in the right way so sometimes that's
what's kind of messing him up and I
think it's probably goes a little deeper
than that
too but as a reminder this is the guy at
the top this is the leader of the
country we we Comfort ourselves even
those of us on the right who recognize
that all the the Grassroots of the left
has gone totally crazy and all the
snowflakes on the college campuses
they've gone totally crazy even now the
corporations they've gone totally crazy
but you know at least there are some
adults in charge
right no and no there there there are no
adults in charge the uh degree of
institutional knowledge and self
individual and political discipline that
we are losing every single day is
immense and uh once it reaches a turning
point we're just not really going to
have a country anymore which is why
people are taking things into their own
hands at the more local level the Texas
National Guard has responded to a
Supreme Court ruling which uh ruled that
the Biden Administration is permitted to
tear
down modest border fencing that the
Texas National Guard had erected to try
to stop the foreign Invasion into Texas
to try to protect Texas's territorial
Integrity the Texas National Guard has
responded
[Music]
by rebuilding the fence I love this this
is so great Biden won't enforce the
Border Biden actually encourages foreign
Nationals to flood across into our
country into Texas in large part uh
because it will give him more votes down
the line record numbers never seen
anything like it in America twice what
we saw under
Obama and Texas says okay you're not
going to enforce the Border we're going
to build a little fence and then Biden
orders his feds to go in and tear down
the fencing he wants to make it easier
for the foreign Nationals to invade the
country run by the cartels by the way
we're not even just talking about you
know a nice young family fleeing poverty
we're talking about the cartels so he
tears that down and then Texas says okay
cool that's great that you made your uh
decision Supreme Court we're going to
put it back up
again this is how the country was set up
you you know you're going to hear the
libs say Texas doesn't support the rule
of law they're a threat to our sacred
democracy there no
Texas what Texas is doing is far more in
line with the founding vision of America
than anything you've seen out of
Washington in recent years Texas is
enacting federalism subsidiarity
protecting that which is most local most
dear why do we have a federal system in
America why do we have power reserved at
least in theory to the states and the
counties and the townships and the local
communities and the family ultimately
because of a deeper principle called
subsidiarity According to which we know
that people are going to be most
accountable to things that are near to
them that are dear to them their family
and their extended family you know their
tribe their kin their Community their
state they're going to be much less
accountable to the to the national
government and the national government's
going to be much less accountable to
them so we're going to try to keep power
at as local a level as possible at at
the sort of level at which that power
can be efficiently and justly wielded
Texas is doing that I hope more more
States follow suit my favorite comment
yory is from El Skeletor 3566 who says
if I were Texas I would ignore the
ruling just like Andrew Jackson did hey
great point and good timing actually
because that was the story I just got to
uh yes Andrew Jackson perhaps he really
said it I always thought it was maybe
apocryphal uh when uh just jce chief
justice Marshall on the Supreme Court
ruled against him he said Justice
Marshall has made his decision now let
him enforce
it whether Jackson said it or not
uh it is a reminder that there are
Jackson balances there is a division of
power and not just at the federal level
but among the feds the national guys you
know and the states and local government
and the local and state governments
should step up really beautiful I can't
wait to see that big beautiful completed
wall 30 m of fencing down there in Texas
speaking of works of
art I'm torn today I'm torn I'm I'm
elated but I'm also a little bit
upset why am I
elated Ryan Gosling has received a Best
Supporting Actor nomination at the
Oscars which nobody watches and nobody
watches 90% of the movies that are even
nominated at the Oscars this year but we
all saw barbie
and some people hated Barbie like my
colleague down in boa Ron because he
didn't understand the movie and some of
us who did understand the movie loved
Barbie because it's a conservative
Masterpiece and the the most clearly
anti-feminist movie since Greta gerwig's
first movie called ladybird I didn't see
little women that might count
too so Ryan
Gosling for all of his kenergy that was
teeming out of him maybe he had some of
those little nicotine pouches I don't
know he gets the nomination Margo Robbie
who did a great job in the movie gets
snubbed for best
actress worse still Greta
Gerwig one of my favorite current
directors and I I watch very few movies
so she you know maybe she'll be the only
director I'll watch for a year or one of
three but gr gwick arguably the most
conservative and Christian director
working in Hollywood today at the
Hollywood level and in that depraved
Place Gamora by the Sea some of us call
it she got snubbed as well for best
director I think that's outrageous some
people think I'm joking or trolling
because they think that Barbie is really
woke or whatever it's not it's really
not I actually don't see how one can
watch
Barbie paying even a modum of attention
and come away thinking that that is a
leftwing movie it's not it's not even a
kids movie by the way some people said
I'm not going to watch Barbie because
it's a kids movie selling toys it's not
even a kids movie but but I see why some
are confused Barbie is a movie for
adults masquerading as a kids movie that
has a conservative message masquerading
as a woke pmic there are all these lines
in the movie about feminism and the
patriarchy and you know and that that's
all people hear but they're not paying
attention to the context of those lines
the lines are
ironic Barbie land which is this
feminist fantasy is a fantasy it's a bad
place there's something rotten and
broken about it and the protagonist
here's a spoiler alert chooses to leave
and go to the real world the world
supposedly dominated by men here's
another spoiler alert the movie opens
with girls being nice and playing with
their little dolls and loving their
little baby dolls and then Barbie comes
along the Barbie toy phenomenon and the
girls start killing their
babies and becoming feminists the whole
thing is presented as a this is a
feminist Revolution and it leads to
women killing their babies and then at
the end of the movie big spoiler
alert the protagonist chooses to leave
Barbie land specifically because she
wants to have a baby she has a a
conversation with the god character the
Ria Pearlman character who created her
and she has a vision of the future that
she wants and the vision is pretty much
just her being a mom and having kids and
so she leaves Barbie land and the the
final funny scene of the movie is she
she's waiting meeting in a in a little
reception area in some non-descript
office building and you all think okay
this is Barbie leaving the fantasy world
to go get a job and go be the real
Barbie you know be the real feminist and
she's not she says I'm here to see my
gynecologist the even the very final
joke is no I'm not going to go be a
career woman no I'm not going to go be
this feminist icon I'm going to be a mom
so anyway I've got much more to say
about Barbie but
it's just clearly conservative I don't
know any I sometimes I will grant you I
read a little deeply into things and I I
try to admit it when I do this one I
just think you could
be you don't need to have read the
collected works of Edmond Burg to
recognize this has a conservative
message to it so what does it mean that
they got snubbed I think it actually
butresses my argument
because it's a conser it's very popular
movie and it's kind of conservative and
maybe that's why it got
snubbed it is at least funny I'm not
sure that that's the reason maybe there
were other internal politics in
Hollywood it is at least funny that the
Ken character is trying to advance the
patriarchy within the feminist Utopia of
Barbie land and uh Ken is the only one
who gets the nomination that's kenergy
patriarchy undefeated
but but that question is even grappled
with in the movie highly recommended
highly recommended that you go see that
movie speaking of a return to Patriot
Archy there is a terrific Bill coming
out of
Oklahoma a bill that would ban
pornography which is something that
pretty much everyone wants other than
the perverts and the weirdos everyone
wants this and everyone has wanted to
ban or severely curtail
pornography forever it's not a
republican thing it's not a Democrat
thing
forever obscenity pornography was banned
in America for most of our history in
most places and then even in the 90s
when the internet came out and and
lawmakers had to Grapple with this new
technological problem both parties came
together to regulate and severely limit
pornography they did it through two
pieces of legislation the communications
decency act which is where you get the
section 230 that protects big tech
companies in some ways from uh oversight
and in the child online protection act
both passed by Republican Democrats
signed by Bill Clinton it was just some
Libs on the court who shot it down and
pretended that there was a First
Amendment right to weird hardcore porn
but most Americans forever have
recognized that there's no right to
watching perverts degrade women on
camera so that other perverts can
degrade themselves in a dark room it's
it's just it's degrading it's not
conducive to human flourishing and so
there is a lawmaker in Oklahoma a state
senator who would make watching porn a
felony and bans seting among people who
are not married so some are saying okay
maybe the guy's gone a little far and
you know it's maybe it's a little
aggressive but he's starting a
negotiation here okay and his position
is far closer to the traditional
American view of these
things his position which is what is he
really saying he's saying hey discourage
people from being perverts and
discourage people from committing
adultery that has been the law in
America it's certainly been the cultural
norm in America and in every reasonable
country for all of
history his position is much closer to
the reasonable one than the position of
the liberals who say yeah go out cheat
on your wives have a thropple chop off
your body parts and be a pervert all the
time this state senator Dusty ders much
much closer to
reality how are we going to get this
across for those of us who recognize
that at least in principle this this law
is a good thing we're going to need to
make some new coalitions we're going to
lose some of the Libertarians some of
the Libertarians are are going to
support us we're going to lose some of
them we're going to lose a lot of
Democrats especially these days some of
the Democrats are going to support us
but speaking of Barbie and confusion
about feminism and what feminism even
means conservatives should Ally with the
feminists here not all the feminists the
sex positive feminists are
lost but feminism used to be deeply
anti-pornography sex negative feminism
was a major strain of feminism and they
opposed it because pornography exploits
and degrades women always all the time
and some of it is particularly degrading
and particularly violent
even the conservatives this is not just
some pie in the sky wouldn't be nice if
we could work with the feminists we did
this on the issue the traditional
conservatives a lost some Libertarians
on the issue but we allied with the
turfs the exclusionary radical feminists
and we've been immens L successful we
have gone a decent way not the whole way
we still have a lot of work to do but
we've gone a decent way toward uh
eradicating for the good of society and
especially for the good of the poor
people who Fallen pray to that confusion
we did that with a weird political
Coalition that included a group
traditionally considered on the left and
and feminist but they were on our side
on this issue same thing could happen
with porn and we should do it the rest
of the show continues now you don't want
to miss it become a member use code
check out for 2 months free on all
annual plans see you over
[Music]
there